-You had to cut your seaso
of "Good Girls" short
by a few episodes
because you were still
in the middle of filming
when this all came down.
Your character Ruby
was shot this year
and you had to drive aroun
in a motorized scooter.
Is that easier or harder
than learning how to ride a bike
after 30 years?
-Easier...
-Okay.
-...but you have
to figure out the speed,
because, you know, when you have
to hit a mark at a certain time,
if you're not walking,
you don't really have control.
So it took a couple of takes
to figure out --
Especially there's a scene
where I'm just circling,
but I'm passing doorways,
and I need to get my line in
at the doorway before I pass
So it took a while to figure out
before I was like --
"And he said what?!",
you know?
[ Both laugh ]
-That's great.
-But I just noticed that
I'm sitting directly in front of
my Jonathan Adler vase,
which is a butt.
[ Both laugh ]
-Yeah, you are.
Sorry.
Too late to fix it.
[ Laughs ]
Are you watching any TV?
We know you to be a great love
of the small screen.
-Yes. "Killing Eve" is back,
so I'm watching that.
-Yeah.
Always great.
-I'm re-watching "West Wing"
and "The Good Wife."
"The Good Wife" holds up.
-Oh, good to know.
-"The Good Wife" has --
"West Wing," it's good,
but there's a lot of
misogyny in it.
-Oh, interesting.
-Yeah.
It's surprisingly
a lot of misogyny.
Every time I watch it,
I'm like, "Ooh, okay."
-Wow.
Not what I would expect.
A good heads-up.
-I know, it's weird.
It's like, you know,
a lot of, like, sly comments
which, you know, would've just
rolled off people's back before.
But watching it in this era,
I'm like,
"Mnh-mnh, Aaron, mnh-mnh.
[ Both laugh ]
Retta, thank you so much
for being here.
It's always such a delight
to see you.
"Good Girls" airs Sunday,
on NBC.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."
-Thanks.